tu lui explique quoi on a un problème
voilà je préfère te le dire on n'aime
pas ta gueule non ça si vous étiez les
sols sera payant on adore non il ya un
truc mais normalement les invités
doivent danser si j'adore
mais si tu vas dans sa caroline mais
c'est une bonne nouvelle
luc je suis pas sûr si tu crois rhodey
rhodes ont
été bien la paix défense de fer de fer
joey starr dans polisse non mais je
danse le rck admirablement tu peux le
faire car
là c'est mc 301 dreux de mon enfance non
personne ne sait pas de son époque mais
le ont fait l'essai avec ce faire
[Musique]
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus